per tutti i ragazzi sono orgoglioso oggi
di portarvi un horror che sta devastando
il web che si chiama fasano phobia
sembra essere tornati i tempi this
lander me quando c'è la loro perché
tutti quanti impazzivano ecco siamo
ritornati linfa smo phobia un gioco dove
di trovare i fantasmi cacciarli oggi
sono col ciccio thomas e giampietro
vediamo cosa riusciamo a combinare
quando visione ma che è sta roba
ciao ragazzi allora ragazzi sia ora il
nostro campo
praga dove siete avete un piegamento di
schiena incredibile ce l'avete fatta voi
sicura ma ci sono le robe cos'è ma siamo
noi gli spettri ma cos'è allora ragazzi
obiettivo numero uno sceglie di voi e
dei capri il tipo di fantasma che se voi
premete jersey capita non è così ed è da
prove trovate veder ci sono tante prove
e bisogna mettere quando metti tutte e
tre le prove ti dirà il tipo di montà
smac è trovato alla fine tipo di
fantasma vedere ora se vogliono in giro
nelle pagine ci sono tanti pd fantasmi
ci sono gli oni juray demone revelant
ombra g il mare poltergeist baci e
aspetto fantasma spirito allora ho fatto
un po di tangi ne è il nome del fantasma
è carol davis parla soltanto alle
persone che sono da sole questo vuol
dire che chi prende la scatola si era la
radio deve chiedersi da solo e parlare
col fantasma chi si prende vita è con
lei che ho parlato fino ai 18 anni
quindi che sun dissing contro lo stesso
vecchio è comunque non vedo niente chi è
qua ma qualcosa ma cosa non capisco
niente l'ente non vedo niente ma dove
guarda qua velenoso vista stornandole
mfp si si lo si fa non me lo dire con
questo sguardo per favola che
bruttissime arredamento primo avanti
madonna orribile l'accesa io sori soldi
soldi soldi che secondo che ha acceso
una lampada mi dai un compito che sono
giro a caso
ma se sei davanti a me perché parli con
lotito che al sesto gioco no va bene
allora io non lo farò mai più
la prima e ultima volta no vabbè è
veramente un ansiolitico
adesso vi aggiungo le ultime due tre
cose che avete più o meno capito cosa
abbiamo fatto per questa stanza piccola
siamo in quattro ci mettiamo seconda
capirla poi i livelli sono intorno
all'ora in strada le impronte che si
rilevano con la cosa viola che la moneta
e lo re le vedi se il fantasma si è
manifestato quindi dopo cinque minuti
praticato qua dietro il computer c'è
questo timer verso a zero lo vedete qua
in rosso noi quando entriamo dentro
qualunque struttura abbiamo cinque
minuti per correre e capire in che
cavolo distanza si trovi il fantasma in
5 minuti da dove cinque quello che ci
può ammazzare incazza ci può ammazzare
questar altre abbiamo finito porca vacca
se che marca mia mi sono cagato nelle
mutande ricacciando ce n'è una che io
adesso andiamo a caccia dei ragazzi io
ma che il protesta ma cosa vedo è
orribile ha ucciso guarda jean ti prego
guardarsi non guardare cambia canale
pomeriggio cinque questa mia 15 un
ragazzino giannini
anzi allora ragazzi ascoltate si chiama
robert moore e risponde alle persone
sono da sole
visto che scatta l'opa da fantasma se ci
riusciamo andiamo
i piedi con 265 sì ma perché c'è questa
eco ceco senti che eco è fighissimo però
no aspetta ciccio poi questo è che
dobbiamo fare una di revaival nostri ci
sei pronto si sono pronto materazzi è
caduto perché ha preso una testata
oppure allora
questo ciò che una volta si chiamava
sbuffa adesso si chiama fobia di giocato
ciccio e famiglia in nove ma ci senti un
gioco
e allora robert moore ci siamo rotti
google salò robert magari avete letto
male marito morto di destra porta la
pronuncia che sbaglia scoperto
probabilmente ei roba che le tipo google
ei roberts o perfino luogo e moore dove
sei ragazze
allora cosa roberto che allora fai
schifo cerchi un frutto demi socera
robert è scritto ciao ragazzi è stato
l'eroe è calato eccolo eccolo e credo
aperto
vieni qua vieni qua perché fini non
eviterà qua abbiamo visto roberto
ragazzi si è manifestato però ci sta ci
sta attaccando delle torce le torce
attaccato sorella che fai schifo
oddio oddio ma non c'è il cup ma che è
successo ragazzi roberto braga o crisi
no no no ma [ __ ] tu mi ha fatto fuori
roberto mannaggia in casa a siliqua
ragazzi vi sentite sono io sono ancora
vivo cioè sono uno spettro è morto sono
morte amici che fanno schifo sono morto
con gli ridono al mio funerale ridono
ridono carichi non c'è più il lavoro
ridi ride lui ride no aspettate sto qua
sto qua vi giuro fai schifo ragazzi la
porta ma va a cagare caricamenti course
sailor e robert lucca permesso charles
moore manifestati allora col mouse 1 lap
a girare con esse la piazza
ti faccio luce perfetto che mi abbia
dato la piazzata davvero youtubers bella
a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono famiglie io qui
siamo solo di una classe dove sta per
manifestarsi charlie moon charlie
charles manifesta team di fatto la
fortuna ora che fate la foto vuole
arrivare qua charlie maronno woods i
brut che facciamo è qua e qua è un'ombra
è un'ombra far ombra di charlie moon e
questa è questa la riprendo lascia
libero youtube facciamole pv slave
l'osso è bellissimo c'è il tasto
abbonati qua sotto per abbonarsi e
seguiteci in line martedì giovedì e
domenica latina
al telefono il tema delle azioni quando
io dai cc rispondi pronto come no oddio
mi ha sussurrato ragazzi vabbè ok adesso
l'esercito che ha ordinato la vita
nell'euro di lavoro ma io però scusa a
tutti e 22 i ragazzi mi fate mi farebbe
gare consiglio fate teca re magi cerotto
ma con un'altra ancor più di prima
perché lanteri altri vucinic
dai che ogni tanto ciao bellassai
amicizia facciamo sì se arrivano altre
chiamate ai vigili che abbandono il
lavoro avrà sto dicendo no ragazzi
qualcuno sta cantando
lawrence mur lo sento anche io qualcuno
che canta nell'orecchio
sì sì anch'io lo sentono sempre charles
charles moore fatti vedere manifesta di
charme
charles moore dio ci ha dato addio
giampiero giampiero è morto samuele è
morto giampiero scappa scappa è morto
c'è più euro e morto a guardare con
cadavere quale guardare come è ovvio che
è più strano lui è così che è morto che
sono così sono vivo secondo me non ho
amici normali sono solo questo usciamo
scappiamo dal camion via via allora le
prove abbiamo scatola libro è morto
gianni mi ero è una prova con la foto e
cita pure i big money grazie gianpi per
essere morto perché qualcuno ha
recuperato la videocamera dalla stanza
no no però non è uguale non cambia
niente
quindi ragazzi questo era il primo
episodio di fascismo phobia fatemi
sapere se volete altri iscritte che hai
lasciato un bel mi piace e noi ci
vediamo come sempre ad un prossimo video
bella ragazza
[Musica]